on change d'univers avec alain degois
qui nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
l'électro ça vous plaît je suis pas
j'adore je l'avais adorée l'arrivée je
suis forcément touzit est sûre j'ai
toujours des désastres acquis c'est
super vous venez ce soir encore ni
quelques pour nous parler de votre tout
premier livre qui s'appelle médine
trappe comme vous y allez en directement
dans le vif du sujet comment est née
l'idée d'écrire un livre
eh bien elle n'est pas née dans ma tête
il faut savoir johanna soudry elle est
née dans la tête d'un éditeur philippe
robinet de kerho qui en fait suivait de
loin
les différentes péripéties de ma
compagnie de ce que je faisais tout est
un jour il m'a contacté en me disant
écoutez papilles je pense que il ya
quelque chose à faire avec votre
histoire avec vous avec ce que vous êtes
et ce que vous faites est ce que vous
avez fait je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
banlieue a besoin 6,2 de connaître aussi
d'autres parcours que ce qu'on entend
habituellement puis ceux qui
construisent aussi les parcours des
autres donc je dis banco allons-y alors
c'est celui qu'on retrouve avec un
bouquin ouais alors justement ce bouquin
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait le
caractérise et de définir est-ce que
c'est plutôt une autobiographie est ce
que c'est plutôt l'histoire de trappes
ya beaucoup de choses dans ce livre une
critique sociale
comment est ce que vous vous percevez
ouvrage c'était très compliqué de deux
parce que si c'est être qu'une
autobiographie autobiographie ben
j'avais l'impression que je me tairai
que c'était mon voilà ça y est c'est moi
donc non c'était c'était à la fois
pouvoir raconter tout ce que j'ai
ressenti c'est c'est comment je me suis
construit moi qui suis venu un peu de
nulle part et et comment j'ai atterri à
trappes
comment trappe mama données manoury
comment effectivement de des choix que
j'ai pu faire dans ma vie font que je
suis venu dans la culture que et puis
bah voilà en étant là il ya des choses
qui me choquent et je dis ça ça me
choque et ça me choque parce que je
parce que je crois vraiment en certaines
valeurs de notre de la culture
aujourd'hui je crois que plus que jamais
il en faut et il faut vraiment réfléchir
parce qu'on parle des banlieues toujours
de façon négative mais il ya des gens
formidables pas je parle pas de moi mais
autour de moi j'ai rencontré j'ai la
chance de rencontrer des gens étonnants
qui ont envie de dire et de se donner à
voir de se faire entendre et bah je
participe et je suis content d'avoir
participé participer à ça voilà donc ce
livre basse et c'est tout ça c'est mes
envies c'est mes coups de gueule
peut-être à des moments donnés mais
incompréhension aussi de notre société
c'est un bonhomme qui se livre voilà
c'est moi et vous étiez plutôt dans
l'ombre auparavant c'était plutôt
l'homme de l'ombre paco sery derrière
tout le monde maintenant il est en plein
dans la lumière avec sony
et alors là on va parler que de lui
maintenant oui c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué je vois bien d'ailleurs que
quelquefois même la presse locale
s'empare de ça mais je ne suis pas
habitué forcément ça mais je crois qu'il
est temps aussi que je lis l'expérience
que j'ai ça fait trente ans que je vis
dans la culture sur le local que ça des
répercussions nationales que wilfrid oui
je prends la lumière ça y est c'est
décidé voilà ça fait plaisir que tu vous
mettez ces spots sur moi je comprends
très bien la lumière alors papy
justement vous intervenez depuis 10 et
30 ans dans le milieu culturel dans les
collèges attrape de sur tout le
territoire saint quentinois ça depuis
des années vous connaissez très bien le
terrain vous êtes vraiment un homme de
terrain on peut le dire
et malgré tout est bien trouver des
subventions fraude la mission impossible
comment est ce que vous expliquez ça
c'est parce que c'est compliqué on vient
sur un champ des subventions de la
culture en fait sont assez compliqué
parce que il ya je dirais ddd structure
des infrastructures culturelles qui sont
lourds qui pompent un maximum d'argent
qui ont des fonctionnements très lourd
pour et pas forcément à la fin de ça
c'est des structures qui qui sont des
sortes de tours d'ivoire qu'on a créé
avec un système culturel français qui
est aussi très très très frileux donc à
qui crée ses propres aux apparatchiks et
donc effectivement quand on est un peu
sur une mini frontières de la culture un
peu en marge et puis que on va
travailler dans des territoires où où
c'est compliqué de parler culture dans
ces territoires là alors soit on est
stigmatisée comme acteur social et ont
pu acteurs culturels
soit on est stigmatisée et et du coup
nous ne serait ce que c'est d'avoir des
subventions et de faire comprendre que
c'est nécessaire que c'est vital
aujourd'hui que ça passera par ça et non
pas seulement par le foot et non pas
seulement par une sorte de 2,2
de vernis culturel qu'on peut qu'on peut
donner non il faut effectivement c'est
compliqué encore aujourd'hui de faire
comprendre ça ça progresse
heureusement notamment sur saint quentin
on a la chance d'avoir la casse qui est
que au niveau de la caci effectivement
il ya une reconnaissance du travail
qu'on fait qui est plus importante qui
nous permet de jeu de tenir mais on
pourrait tellement faire plus on
pourrait tellement aller plus loin aux
pensées qui a une culture à deux
vitesses en france et sur 50 en effet il
ya vraiment les gens qui sont sur le
terrain et puis les autres qu'on pouvoir
finalement mais je pense vraiment qu'il
y a encore une fois dans notre système
et alice est valable à saint quentin
comme ailleurs une vraie une vraie
disproportion dans dans les financements
de la culture dans notre pays et c'est
clair que moi j'appelle dès ce soir
johanna soudry et wilfrid à
l'insurrection culturel de 2,2 des
banlieues mais vraiment de 2,2 dire
donnez nous donnez vous à voir
c'est peut-être pour ça que le bouquin
mal j'ai dit oui parce que je disais
merde moi aussi je j'ai envie de le dire
j'ai pas envie de baisser la tête ou ou
d'accepter des systèmes qui ne me
conviennent pas qui ne sont pas justes
pour pour pour les on est dans un pays
républicain je veux pas être un banni de
la république et je veux pas et qui est
cette république doit aussi prendre
c'est prendre les données la culture
partout pour rien c'est pas un livre
pour régler vos comptes pour autant non
mais je n'aurai pas de compte je dise
qui sait ce qui s'est fait après il ya
des gens qui prennent qui peut mal le
prendre parce qu'ils vont se sentir visé
parce qu'effectivement ils ont participé
aussi à cet assaut à ce phénomène assez
de structures là maintenant je repasse
et des êtres humains ils passeront comme
moi et mes en revanche oui de dire c'est
ça d'ailleurs les choses bougent aussi
et j'espère encore une fois que leur
réflexion a eu sur la culture qui se
joue dans l'eure dans leur ville va va
bouger
et de façon positive de dire les choses
c'est pas forcément d'être contre eux
c'est dire vous faites ça mais pourquoi
vous faites ça et on va le faire
ensemble voulait pas pourquoi vous avez
peur de quoi
vous avez peur de quoi je vais pas vous
mangez gg je mange à ma faim mais en
revanche je ne suis pas d'accord sur
cette façon là ou peut-être qu'il va
falloir avoir en face de vous des
interlocuteurs nous sommes pas que des
acteurs nous sommes aussi des
interlocuteurs de la culture qui se joue
ici il ya des gens qu'ils entendent des
gens qu'ils entendent moins il ya des
gens qui sont tus il ya des gens qui
sont dans leur dans leur tour d'ivoire
il ya des gens qui sont dans leur petit
pouvoir et qui se sont laissé bouffer
par ça vivement qu'on arrive à avoir
deux mandats et pas trahi et pas 3 et
pas 4 en france faut que les politiques
et que deux mandats c'est ce qui est
bien avec papy c'est que les choses sont
toujours clair et c'est pour ça qu'on a
invité ses employés culture alors vous
revenez dans ce livre sur votre passé
vous avez rencontrées vous avez
découvert djamel vous avez vous aussi
permis à sa mère de se lancer dans le
théâtre
est-ce que ça justement c'est une fierté
pour vous juste d'avoir réussi à aider
accompagner des artistes en devenir
et lorsque ce qui est super c'est que
c'était pas ce n'était pas une volonté
de ma part au départ c'est vraiment là
on est dans la relation humaine c'est
bah c'est un jamel qui veut faire son
premier one man show et puis en face de
lui il n'a que moi comme interlocuteur
et je m' improvisent quelques parts
metteur en scène du premier spectacle de
jamel c'est tout neuf ça marche
et puis ben voila l enthousiasme me fait
que on va essayer de jouer ailleurs on
joue avec la verrière ça marche on joue
à rambouillet sa marque qui allons à la
capitale donc on monte à la capitale et
et ça marche il se fait reconnaître et
voilà l'histoire se fait arnaud pareil
c'est pas ce que je me dis c'est que
c'est pas quelqu'un peu à qui veut dire
non tu sais où tu es là tu as du talent
j ouer c'est super ce que tu veux faire
ballon et ben je tiens je te fait jouer
ici je te fait jouer là oui tu vas
donner des ateliers pour pouvoir
constater d'intermittent et puis la
compagnie sera là derrière toi tu fais
ton premier spectacle
eh ben on va t'aider à imprimer à
trouver une salle voilà et puis derrière
il ya yarn au joaillier qui écrit avec
lui qui est issu lui aussi de cette
compagnie ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on voit que c'est dans la durée
les choses se jouent parce que déclic
est là et que battue commence un angle
au bout de trois ans quatre ans cinq ans
peut-être que celui qui a du talent
quelques trucs en plus parce qu'il ya
cette famille parce qu'il ya cette
compagnie il sait qu'il peut s'appuyer
et ça sera le petit coup de pouce le
regard le la compréhension de ce qu'il a
à me dire qui va faire que je dis bah
ouais on y va on embarque aujourd'hui
c'est même plus moi qu'il fait c'est
morelia keynes et c'est nouradine c'est
c'est effectivement d'autres de la
compagnie hamel ndi qui sont eux qui
nous dira papy regarde j'ai rencontré
celui-là ou où ce jeune là si on tient
il va donner quelque chose cette jeune
fille elle est incroyable alain hiver à
défendre voilà et c'est bien aujourd'hui
c'est que le plus tout seul c'est qu'il
ya tout tous ces gens derrière qui
oeuvrent pour reconnaître et et
accompagner les talents vous êtes le
papier donc de cette compagnie et de
théâtre comédien metteur en scène
découvreur de talents sculpteur aussi on
découvre ça dans votre livre
pour les personnes qui ne vous qu'ils ne
savaient pas encore auteur aujourd'hui
alors c'est quoi la prochaine étape non
enfin je pense
non mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
d'explorer un jeune âge vous convie à
explorer aussi tous et tous et tous et
toutes les possibles j'ai la chance de
pouvoir moi effectivement aujourd'hui
explorer la structure c'est un truc qui
me qui me prend de plus en plus j'ai
envie d'aller plus loin là dedans j'ai
envie de l'aider de voir ce que j'ai à
dire est encore à dire avec ça je pense
que ça c'est la voilà qui risque d'être
prépondérant dans les années qui
viennent
et puis l'accompagnement d'artistes
reste quelque chose de
de vraiment étonnant pour moi et qui me
nourrit donc je vais continuer ça et
puis voilà mais bien peu vous retrouvez
aussi sur scène
j'enchaîne directement parce que vous
avez quelques bases dans lysistrata aux
côtés d'une autre notre comédienne de
déclic 4 ça sera samedi donc le 26
janvier à 20h45 à maurepas à l'espace
albert camus et puis et bien j'ai envie
d'enchaîner c'est avec un beau spectacle
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
vendredi 25 et samedi 26 janvier pour
isabelle et la bête avec sanseverino que
vous connaissez très bien puisque c'est
un grand ami à vous j'ai commencé avec
116 c'est lui qui m'a donné une mes
premiers cours de clown de théâtre à
elancourt à l'école de théâtre
d'elancourt à l'époque donc et on a créé
notre premier spectacle qui s'appelait
les frères tamuly ensemble donc allé
voir sans cesse
c'est un monsieur qu'il faut voir sur
scène alors je continue
vous allez devoir vous pas je sais pas
qui passait là qu'il va valider ou non
votre agenda avec selex alors après je
sais pas si les artistes vous les
connaissez il ya un as des as et emily
loizeau qui joueront donc demain soir
jeudi 24 janvier à 20h30 à la batterie
de guyancourt et puis eiffel ce groupe
de rock français avec déjà très connus
jouera sur la grande la grande scène
pardon du chéné vendredi 8 février à 20
heures
voilà pour l'agenda qui on rappelle ce
livre donc de papy alain degois qui va
rester en plateau johanna merci beaucoup
première c'est votre dernière chronique
sur à près de 4 fois tv films mais si
c'est la révélation histoire voilà papy
merci encore recommencement vous êtes un
vrai phoenix et papineau même on l'avait
déjà dit 100 plateaux valeur a précisé
je vais à la sonnerie qui oeuvre aussi
qui officie avec les théâtres johanna
effectivement est venu tâter
l'improvisation j'ose dire dans nos
ateliers aussi est venu sur la radio
marmite fm 82.4 aussi faire ses premiers
pas
à nice avec nouradine agne qu'on salue
en passant et j'ai pas d'inquiétude pour
johanna de d'aller explorer justement
d'autres pans artistique elle a sûrement
qu'elle va qu'elle va nous dévoiler à
ses inventions peu bas en attendant je
vous propose parce que voilà ça fait
presque quatre ans que je suis ici de
regarder une petite vidéo de toutes ces
années de tout ce travail là on a quand
même bien rigolé tim burton nous emmène
avec alice faire un voyage dans le
fantastique au pays des merveilles comme
toujours
tim burton nous plonge dans le gothique
et l'absurde elle y retrouve le
chapelier fou qui n'est autre que denis
dette
tu fais une princesse avant de me
transformer en nombreux ouvrages quand
on a un look
arnaud arnaud tsamère quel jeu d'acteur
quel humour quand on s'est rencontrés
trajano et moi il n'a suffi que d'un
regard pour pour pour commencer
l'interview
vous avez vu normal c'est un beau cadeau
quand même pour la journée de la femme
j'enfile mon string léopard et j'arrive
bah voilà mal et j'ai confiance et
enfants ça y est nous traçons est arrivé
ça fait un sommaire amateurs de beaux
paysages de sensations cette discipline
vous séduira un dernier conseil mieux
vaut avoir l'estomac bien accroché
et comme on est ici grasses beurre de
bresse à eau
une fois papilles alors de quoi vous en
pensez quoi toutes ces prestations de
johanna incroyable ce formidable c'est
un engagement dont chaque personnage
bravo jaune va bravo merci beaucoup joué
à la merci d'avoir donc collaborer avec
la rédaction de télé fils durant ses
quatre années et la chaîne est bien
évidemment nous vous souhaitons messages
que j'ai reçus de remerciements et de
soutien voilà ça fait plaisir d'avoir un
retour positif merci encore à tous plein
de réussite pour vous juste une pause
alain degois vous restez sur ce plateau
asie ceni va nous rejoindre on va parler
d'actualité pour l'instant une
conséquence inattendue de la neige les
retards pour passer le permis de
conduire les explications une des
conséquences de la neige et du verglas
il est moins facile de passer son permis
de conduire depuis le début de la
semaine des reports de cours et des
annulations de dernière minute sont
constatés comme dans cette auto école le
problème qui se passe c'est pour les
élèves qui sont en préparation d'examens
qui sont proches de l'examen puisque
déjà des difficultés pour les préparer
et surtout on ne peut pas savoir à
l'avancé si le l'examen aura lieu ou non
des élèves qui pourrait faute d'un
accord avec les auto-écoles être amenés
à payer des heures de conduite en plus
le problème de la neige associée depuis
mardi à la grève des inspecteurs du
permis de conduire qui protestent contre
le nouveau permis européen
mise en place depuis le 19 janvier dans
cette auto écoles de montigny en tout
cas la grève n'a pas eu d'impact